Vielleicht kennt ihr das folgende Phänomen
ja auch: Ihr erinnert Euch an Dinge, die so
gar nicht passiert sind oder aber ihr seid
Euch ganz sicher, dass ein Ereignis ganz anders
gewesen ist als es Andere behaupten.
Klar - das könnte reiner Zufall sein.
Was aber ist los, wenn sich viele, ja sogar
einige hundert Menschen falsch erinnern?
Genau das meint der sogenannte Mandela-Effekt.
Was diese wirklich äußerst mysteriöse Theorie
mit einem tot geglaubten Mann und auch mit
Star Wars zu tun hat und ob sie vielleicht
ein Indiz für die Existenz eines Paralleluniversums
ist - Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Vielen Dank für Euren Themenvorschlag bei
Whats App.
Die ganze Story nahm seinen Lauf, als sich
die Autorin und selbsternannte Geisterjägerin
Fiona Broom mit einigen anderen Leuten über
den ehemaligen Präsidenten von Südafrika
Nelson Mandela unterhielt.
Ein Freiheitskämpfer, der im Jahr 1918 geboren
wurde und im Jahr 2013 gestorben war.
Doch der Zeitpunkt seines Todes ist tatsächlich
der Knackpunkt der ganzen Sache.
Denn nicht nur Fiona Broom selbst, sondern
eben auch viele andere Menschen sind felsenfest
in dem Glauben, dass Mandela eben nicht im
Jahr 2013, sondern bereits 30 Jahre zuvor
gestorben war.
Bei dem gerade erwähnten Gespräch waren
also alle schockiert, dass der schon seit
langer Zeit tot geglaubte Nelson Mandela eben
erst viele Jahre später gestorben sein sollte.
Und wie bereits gesagt: Nicht nur Fiona Broom,
sondern zahlreiche andere Menschen irrten
sich in dieser Sache gewaltig.
Sogar in Zeitungen wurde darüber berichtet,
denn auch ein paar Geschichtsbücher sollen
Mandelas Tod angeblich schon für den Zeitraum
von vor mehr als 20 Jahren, also in den 80er
Jahren, festgehalten haben.
Und nicht nur das: Die Menschen konnten sich
sogar an einige Details seines Todes erinnern.
Nämlich, dass er beispielsweise einsam in
einem Gefängnis ums Leben gekommen war.
Ihren Behauptungen zufolge war er auch niemals
südafrikanisches Staatsoberhaupt und Broome
selbst hatte auch detailreiche Erinnerungen
an Mandelas Begräbniszeremonie.
Das alles beschreibt sie auf ihrem Blog und
bezeichnet das ganze Phänomen als “Mandela-Effekt”.
Wissenschaftliche Belege gibt es dafür aber
nicht.
Und so kann man den Mandela-Effekt im Großen
und Ganzen als eine Art Verschwörungstheorie
bezeichnen.
Darüber hatten wir ja auch schon einmal ausführlich
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction berichtet.
Doch die Nelson Mandela-Story ist nicht das
einzige Beispiel dafür, dass sich Menschen
an Fakten erinnern, die so eben überhaupt
nicht passiert sind.
Ja, dass sich vielleicht sogar ein Großteil
der Menschen in genau derselben Sache irrt.
Wie zum Beispiel der berühmte Satz aus den
Star-Wars Filmen, an den sich ja wohl jeder
von Euch erinnert: “Luke, I am your father”!
Doch tatsächlich heißt der Satz anders,
denn Darth Vader erwähnt den Namen seines
Sohnes nicht mit einer einzigen Silbe.
Stattdessen lief das Gespräch so ab: Darth
Vader: „ Obi Wan never told you what happened
to your father.“
Luke: „He told me enough.
He told me you killed him.“
Darth Vader: „No, i am your father!“
Und jetzt kommen die Paralleluniversen ins
Spiel.
Forschungsteams der Physik sind schon seit
einiger Zeit auf der Spur möglicher Parallel-Welten.
Auch über dieses sogenannte “Multiversum”
hatten wir hier erst vor kurzem ausführlich
berichtet - eine wirklich spannende Sache.
Kurz gesagt gehen manche Menschen davon aus,
dass es völlig unterschiedliche Universen
gibt, in denen nicht nur eine andere Physik
herrscht, sondern auch unterschiedlich viele
Raumdimensionen vorkommen.
Doch wie genau wird diese These des Multiversums
in der Physik erklärt?
Zurückzuführen ist sie auf das Standardmodell
der Kosmologie, nach der sich das All unmittelbar
nach seiner Entstehung ausgedehnt hat und
dies auch immer noch tut - in der Fachsprache
auch “Inflation” genannt.
Manche Regionen sind demnach früher zum Stillstand
gekommen als andere - sie haben sich quasi
wie Blasen in kochendem Wasser abgesondert
- bildlich gesprochen natürlich.
Und so wäre auch unser Universum nur eine
Blase neben vielen weiteren.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Alan Guth: “In
einem Universum, das sich grenzenlos inflationär
ausdehnt, passiert alles, was überhaupt passieren
kann, und zwar unendlich oft."
Jedenfalls würden sich die verschiedenen
Universen gegenseitig beeinflussen.
Auf den Mandela-Effekt bezogen, bedeutet das,
dass jedes Ereignis für sich quasi eine neue
Zeitlinie und somit auch einen eigenen Kosmos
für sich eröffnet.
Bei jedem Quanten-Ereignis, das stattfindet,
entsteht also ein neuer Zeitstrahl und ein
weiteres Universum.
Die Realität weicht in gewisser Weise somit
also ab.
Wenn sie dann aber auf die Wirklichkeit trifft,
wird sie durch abweichende Erinnerungen zum
Ausdruck gebracht.
Sind die also gleichzeitig ein Indiz dafür,
dass wir in verschiedenen Varianten existieren?
Die Anhänger des Mandela-Effekts jedenfalls
sind von der Existenz der Paralleluniversen
überzeugt.
Demnach basiert dieses mysteriöse Phänomen
eben darauf, dass diese Dinge, die in unserer
Welt als Irrtum gelten, in einer anderen Welt
den Tatsachen entsprechen.
Die Quantenphysik dagegen kann bis heute nicht
wirklich etwas Gesichertes zu der Existenz
von Paralleluniversen sagen.
Der Mandela-Effekt beruht also bisher keineswegs
auf wissenschaftlichen Tatsachen oder Fakten.
Eine weitere mögliche Erklärung für dieses
Phänomen der falschen Erinnerung kommt aus
der Neurowissenschaft.
Experten gehen davon aus, dass hierbei eine
Fehlfunktion des menschlichen Gehirns vorliegt.
Denn dieses funktioniert ganz anders als ein
Computer oder ein riesiges Archiv.
Vielmehr funktioniert es durch Assoziationen,
die in einer Art verzweigten Netz gespeichert
und abgerufen werden können.
Und na klar, die Fehlerquote hierbei ist nicht
gerade klein.
Und somit scheint es bislang so, als sei die
menschliche Erinnerung oftmals trügerisch
und unsicher - und durch verschiedene Faktoren
wie beispielsweise der eigenen Persönlichkeit
und dem Umfeld geprägt.
Auch, wenn es vielen Menschen offensichtlich
schwer fällt, das zu akzeptieren.
Wenn ihr auch Themen vorschlagen wollt, dann
kommt hier zu unserer WhatsApp-Community!
Einfach draufklicken und ihr erfahrt vor allen
anderen vom aktuellen Video!
Und hier geht es weiter mit Clixoom.